let me just start off by saying it's a
great great pleasure for me to be at
Stanford both the location and the fact
that I'm with you at the Graduate School
of Business is a tremendous privilege as
y'all have heard from Dean Jost I was
never an MBA myself but to counter an
MBA environment and Business School any
educational environment is a tremendous
privilege I have to say I envy you guys
I think this is just the most
extraordinary extraordinary campus and
it's really great privilege to me to be
here I would also just like say if I'm a
particular for any faculty in the room
indeed on behalf of you and your
predecessors I would on behalf the
kinsey I'd say thank you to Stanford
Stanford has been an unbelievable source
of talent and leadership for McKinsey
over many many years many have left
McKinsey there in other leadership
positions but if I could say to all of
you on behalf of your predecessors the
big thank you from McKinsey it's just
been a one of wonderful privilege for us
now what I thought I'd like to do
justice with those feuds were the
background is there are two things that
I thought I'd like to talk to you about
tickly as this is sponsored by the GMP
and the Graduate School of Business
I'd like to give you a sense of what at
least in my view is on the minds of CEOs
across the world not just in the u.s.
not just in Europe this will include
Japan China Southeast Asia Brazil Chile
one of the great curses of my life but
one of the great joys of my life is I
get to travel a lot and I do get to meet
a lot of CEOs I don't know them always
very well some are sitting in this room
today they do get a sense of what's on
their mind and I talk to my colleagues a
lot you know who work with CEOs now I
just wanted to give you an idea of what
the global themes that I think are on
the minds of CEOs and I think will be on
their minds the next three or four years
independent of the unknowns that are
going to happen so give you a sense if
you look at the global context what's on
the mind of CEOs and then if I'm a very
very briefly just what I think it's
going to mean for leadership skills
going forward I think it's going to be
different from what it has been in the
last ten years and I hope that some of
that will resonate with you whatever you
choose to do whether you choose going to
business public sector banking hedge
funds consulting I hope some of those
things will resonate with you I'll speak
for about 20-25 minutes that's okay and
then throw it open for questions and so
there's anyone to pursue with me
specifically leave it to the request
now before I do that I was told that for
some extraordinary reason you'd like to
know a little bit about me apart from
the glowing testimonial that Dean just
gave my my love of cricket so I will
just spend a little bit of time talking
about myself not just because I like to
talk about myself but partly I think
it'll give you a sense about how I think
about things I also think it's very
important whenever you hear anyone
giving a point of view what they think
where are they coming from it's not a
question we are sofmap where are you
coming from what's your background
what's your nationality what's your
experience for all of us victims of our
own prejudice so if I give you a little
bit of a sense of my own prejudices so
that you can put what I say into context
now as Dean said I joined McKinsey when
I was 28 years old I'd worked in
business I had no MBA I have to say that
when I joined McKinsey I did not know
what DCF stood for that was quite
unusual even in those days if anything
that Kim's was even more technically
minded it was it was that it was a an
experiment in for the first two years of
my life at McKinsey I was taught a bad
experiment in recruiting non MBAs so I
joined straight I had no thoughts of
being a consultant I'd always thought my
career would be either in business or in
academics by a series of flute and I
think fluke and circumstance plays a
large part in any of us allies it
certainly did with me I joined McKinsey
at 28 I frankly struggled the first two
years I always enjoyed it so I was
learning so much I was getting the MBA
experience in two years as well as
meeting some type of his people but
gradually got the hang of it decided
this is the sort of environment that I
like not all my friends at the time did
but it suited me partly because I'd
worked in business and I was able to
make a comparison and I stayed through I
worked mostly in the consumer product
sector I led the consumer practice in
McKinsey for eight years where we didn't
have one I started it actually that's
packaged birds and retail that those are
the industries I know well I led that
practice I then led our marketing
practice and then I led the London
office of McKinsey before for reasons
that I cannot possibly explain to you my
colleagues elected me managing director
two years ago now some of you will ask
me or
asked me already what's it like being
the CEO of McKinsey and the answer is a
I'm not a CEO I am NOT a CEO it is a
professional partnership most of the
people who have talked to you or will
talk to you actually run companies
McKinsey is not a company and I most
certainly do not run it it's a
partnership we have two hundred and
ninety directors senior partners and six
hundred junior partners are principals
so they're nine hundred people who own
the company
they're the shareholders but the ethos
at lease of McKinsey like most
professional service firms is an
independent professional partnership so
if you ask me how many people report to
me the honest answer would be one my
assistant another answer would be nine
hundred and forty and neither answer be
two hundred and ninety so it's a very
very odd structure of partnership
structure I I think something can be as
being like a herder of cats and so I'm
not sure that I can you know sort of
give you a sort of what's it like being
a CEO I have a lot of authority which I
can use or abuse and Lenny would tell me
I do a bit of both sometimes I have very
little power I have very little power
indeed which is unlike many many CEOs I
happen to believe that I think a
leadership characteristic in many
organizations is moving from power
towards Authority but in a partnership
you depend solely on personal
credibility and influence and people
saying yeah that sounds reasonable we
got to get things done so it's a
different type of structure it's a it's
around leading people I won't go on too
long but I think it's a different type
of role for most CEOs the second point
is as Dean just mentioned I've been
elected not appointed so to an extent
it's appear type role and I have to
recognize that it's much more like a a
political process in that sense it's an
election rather than an appointment so
having acknowledged what I do is that
are rather different from the normal
CEOs or the normal leaders that you will
see nevertheless I think what I have to
deal with very similar to people who
actually run organizations whether
they're on the public
set to the not-for-profit space foreign
companies and let me just give you the
four things that I focus on which I
think having watched CEOs is what
practically all CEOs or leaders of
academic institutions or leaders of
civil service departments also have to
worry about so my point is although what
I am is very different actually what I
have to do through a different forum is
quite similar number one setting the
culture in my case reaffirming the
culture I think all leaders of
organizations whatever they are have to
think first and foremost about setting
the culture that they want their
organization number two
identifying appointing and building the
leadership team again I think this is a
generic skill that you have to do how do
you appoint and develop the leadership
team although people don't report to me
I do have the power of appointment who
runs the who runs the West Coast
practice who runs our private equity
practice who's going to oversee
recruiting who's going to drive our
initiative to improve the retention of
women in McKinsey for example all these
I have power of appointment so there's
appointments and building the team is
something I have to do again I think
very similar to what most CEOs have to
do number three telling the story I
think Steve Ballmer has spoken to you he
talked that being the cheerleader pick
your language I know exactly what he
means telling the story in Mackenzie's
case it's mostly internal one of the
things I thank God for is that I didn't
have to deal with investors in analyst I
just do not have to deal with them you
know our investors an analyst to my
colleagues sometimes that can be even
tougher you can get tougher questioning
but I know them I know them and I can
look everyone in the face I know
individually so that's telling the story
about what you're trying to do what the
firm is trying to do talking to new
recruits talking to people leaving the
firm talking to the partners talking to
clients telling the story is what I call
it being the cheerleader is number three
and then the final one is defining the
priorities defining the themes that are
going to shape my time as a managing
director this if it was in corporate
speak it would be the strategic agenda
and there's lots of different words that
you can use I use the word themes what
the themes that were going to focus on
so the tasks that I actually spend my
time on a setting and in my case
reaffirming the culture appointing and
building the leadership team telling the
story and then just defining of the
priorities very quickly for those of you
that might be interested in McKinsey as
an institution I won't spend much time
talking about McKinsey don't panic for
those who are interested in it just what
what are the themes that I have chosen I
just like to give a flavor another
individual would have picked three
different themes this wasn't mandated
it's what I chose them but just give you
a flavor theme number one there three I
think coping with more than three or
four theme many CEOs have eight or nine
themes I personally think that's too
many I think one is great - is it good
and three is okay I've got three and I
can't quite get it down to two I'm still
working on it
theme number one is redefining what
McKinsey means by problem solving we've
always defined ourselves our clan says
that people suck you know define
problems help clowns identify
opportunities help them deal with
challenges and issues and traditionally
I think it's fair to say that we have
had a similar approach for
problem-solving that is usually embedded
in business schools very analytical very
very focused on structured thinking very
focused on discipline very focused on
process and that's great I think it's
important my belief and I think many of
my colleagues believe is that that is no
longer enough and then we have to spend
much more attention on the softer or the
people sides of problem-solving why do
people do what they do why do companies
make the decisions that they do what's
going on in people's lives which will
affect how motivated they are to do the
rational thing we all know and you'll
have read and believe me it's true 50
percent of decisions that are made are
not rationally rational so why do they
go on happening and there's practically
always a good reason and practically
always a good reason there's somebody on
two legs
people on two legs so theme number one
is how can we incorporate a deeper
understanding what motivates behavior
good and bad some of the things that
motivate decisions may not be very good
but spending a lot more time
understanding that side alongside our
traditional analytical and process
skills is something I feel very very
passionate
I don't think it's a redefinition of
what we do is about problem solving but
it's bringing this aspect into what we
do which means we have to change our
behaviors how much time we spend with
clouds how human we are as people the
language I use for that is IQ c q r q IQ
you'll understand that's intelligence
insight ideas
traditionally what firms like asked you
know associated with CQ is what I call
capability and competence this is where
Mackenzie's been investing very heavily
for the last five years
deep marketing knowledge deep corporate
finance knowledge deep IT knowledge do
you understand how processes work really
understanding how ha storing works just
a bit some examples is of competences in
my view the days of pure generalist
management and pure generous consulting
her over it's both specialized knowledge
and integrative I think we spotted that
you know quite some time ago that we
have to continue and the final cue is
our cue it's what I call relational
quotient I don't mean just getting on
with people being nice and being able to
drink a cup of gin and tonics with
people I don't mean that I mean
understanding how people relate to you
to each other to their company and to
decisions since it's a part of a company
ethos our County 'those so that's team
number one
IQ c q are you trying to redefine and
broaden the definition of
problem-solving I believe if we can do
that I think it'll lead to better
outcomes for our clients and I think
more motivation and satisfaction for
people seem number two is Asia Asia
you'll have heard that before
this is not the most staggering insight
in the world
everybody knows it's important but
knowing it's important to making it
happen is something different
Mackenzie's been in Asia for a long time
we opened up in China in 1993 long
before any other professional services
firm and we have them puffed and we
struggled and hit our head against a
brick wall for example you've been in
India for a long time we've been in
Japan a long time but we really are
doubling down just an example on that
we've had 16 partners moved to Shanghai
in the last 15 months so really really
getting serious that Asia I don't need
to tell you why we're doing that you
know better than I do but really really
getting serious about that now come on
to this it it actually has a lot of
challenges for culture how you think
about things and how you do do things
you all know about you know GDP moving
eastwards all that stuff you all know
about China and India it's going to have
far far bigger implications and the way
organizations around in my view than
anybody's yet realize the final theme on
my agenda before I go on to talk about
the purpose this talk is innovation
innovation McKenzie was quite good at
talking to plants about their need to
innovate we haven't always been frank
with you being quite as good ourselves
we are really looking at challenging our
orthodoxes of the way we do things to
particular areas I'd pick on one is our
people how we serve plants how we deal
with people you know you would have
heard from too about the people about
you know the consulting lifestyle how we
work how we deal with clance we're going
to really really tackle that head-on and
a lot of that is innovating the way we
work using technology using flexibility
if any profession could then should be
flexible its consulting people coming in
and out you know we know it's very
difficult for a law firm or a Taxation
Department or people are offshore
engineering to be flexible we can be and
so making flexibility really work is
something we're going to do making
diversity a reality we talk about my kid
everybody talks at McKinsey being the
benchmark of a diverse culturally
diverse organization I wish that were
true I wish that were true
yes we have every nationality in the
world yes we have a lot of women that
work for us but that is not my
definition of diversity most of our
people have MBAs most have engineering
quantitative backgrounds most would fit
in
this room within a nanosecond I think
diversity is diversity of personality
diversity of academic background and we
are actively looking to recruit example
people people from liberal arts
backgrounds from medical backgrounds we
even recruited somebody recently who's a
priest and I want to push that I think
it's very very good
maybe it's the Dali Lama I show you
maybe you are right that's why I'm here
so to do that so diversity to meet
diversity to me is a lot more a lot more
than women in different races I think it
goes cult free I think is the way people
think people's academic backgrounds has
a huge influence on the way we think
we're really really pushing that very
hard second point of innovation our
shuttle is the knowledge we are a
knowledge institution we're probably
more like an academic institution we are
like a business we invest hugely in
knowledge development
we're often cited as a role model for
if that is true god help everybody else
that's all I can say and we are really
really looking at that very seriously
one thing that we have not yet responded
to and we had the most fascinating
lecture from a professor of psychology
is how the Internet and how teenagers
learn and communicate with each other I
don't know if you watch how people blog
and exchange information we're looking
to apply that to the knowledge base so
that you build knowledge through
interaction preferably personal but
through technology these sorts of
technique of knowledge exchange we're
really working on and we were invest
massively here I just want to give you a
flavor of that and then finally we're
going to get a bit more sassy about the
way we deal with clowns we have a very
very methodical very disciplined
extremely professional approach we're
going to experiment with new ways of the
work or the way we work with tasks how
to communicate with them how we relate
to them how we use different
problem-solving approaches so just to
give you just one person in my case
Manji director McInnes view of the
themes that i have when you hear other
CEOs I'm sure they talked about themes
it's about redefining problem-solving
and broadening it really doubling down
on Asia and focusing on innovation
particularly the way we handle our
people and particularly in terms of
knowledge development
just a little bit of a long introduction
but I hope he gives you a sense sort of
where I come from the things that I
worry about now let me just move briefly
onto the main core of what I wanted to
say to you which is what's on the mind
of global CEOs and what do I think will
be on the mind of global CEOs there are
five themes I'm not going to spend much
time on them I'm just going to list them
if any of them intrigued you perhaps you
can expand on them in the questions
theme number one strategy is back a
strategy is back now strategy I've
always thought is a cyclical thing I
think most themes in business are
cyclical three years ago strategy was
dead you need strategy it's a waste of
time you can't predict anything and
there's a lot of nonsense going on about
strategy three years ago there's a lot
of nonsense going on about strategy now
about it's all about strategy again
that's not true either what I'm saying
is there is a time for strategy and
there's a time for implementation
there's a time for growth as a time for
cost-cutting there's a time and a cycle
of companies and industries now is the
time and I think it's gonna go on unless
there's a real economic crash we're
really rethinking about strategy and
specifically the basics of strategy of
where and how to operate not compete
come on to that how to operate what's
driving that every country I go into the
world virtually every CEO I talk to the
two themes that they are worried about
is growth not margin not not course its
growth but this time relate that is risk
how much risk are they prepared to take
in order to grow and how do they deal
with the financial community and these
virtually everywhere doesn't matter to
Japan or in China or in a family
business in Southeast Asia or in Brazil
that keeps coming through there's a lot
of empirical evidence that says growth
is the ultimate determinant not just of
value but also of survival there's a lot
of pressure on companies to grow and
it's this growth risk trade-off which i
think is absolutely Nexus CEOs are more
thoughtful in my view they met much of
the financial community and certainly
than the median the public on the risk
side of it a profitability is extremely
high at the moment in my view the
systemic risks in the system and some of
these
has been grossly underestimated but the
CEO sort of know that and they didn't
want to do about it most of them do not
want to get the investments yes I know
we're doing very well but really it's
much risk and you think you just didn't
do that and what's your sound price but
they do worry about it a lot and the
other thing that's linked to it which i
think is not talked too much and i think
has gone outside the academic a gender
as well as time frames over what time
frame do you think about growth and
strategy and there's a definite cultural
and intellectual clash going on here the
cultural trend is towards short-termism
the intellectual trend when you look at
investment I think is towards more of a
long-term look and there isn't any good
theory at the moment for thinking about
timeframes of strategy I think I might
say about three or four years ago that
there was quite a lot about piecing I
know there's a lot of intranet all sort
of died I hope some day some day some
academics will pick up this issue of
time frames how sustainable a strategy
is is a very very important part of the
value of a company and that's something
that CEOs are really wrestling with but
if you when you go to Asia where they do
take up a very very long term view so
theme number one is if I call it the
strategic agenda of this interplay
between growth risk and timeframes and
there's a lot of muddled thinking going
on between the two team number two
you're now this is deeply boring but
it's important it's globalization mark
29 in my view at the very early stages
of globalization and my view were just
beginning to see some of the management
implications of what globalization is
actually meaning for companies the
reality is for most firms particularly
American firms is that globalization is
going to new markets in Asia that's
going global no it's not it's often it's
exporting and increasingly going global
on the supply side of shoring
outsourcing could it what you want
what's happening now is we're moving
beyond that to actually redefining
organizations in a global context the OP
what is called offshoring which i think
is a complete misnomer about what's
going on and supply chain I just leave
that is beginning to affect how
organizations actually
operator I'll tell you a story I told
the CEO one of the big semi conductor
manufacturers world leader and he said
look I've got a big problem he said I
need a new CFO of one of my divisions
and I've got two candidates one is in
the US gets paid 750 thousand dollars a
year's class class class and you know
plus plus in the States and only means
three times that and the other kind of
it is in India and he gets paid $40,000
and I think the Indian person is better
what do I do
the best one so if I promote the Indian
and then what do I pay him three million
or sixty thousand dollars if I plant 3
million what does that say to the
organization of whom now 3,000 in India
if I don't how can I say you'll remember
the top management team what do I do
so we're beginning to see that and this
is going to happen this is now finance
is going to happen in HR it's going to
happen in marketing fraction this is a
company that had a 60% of its sales were
global but the culture in the history of
the company is 100% American and they're
going to confront very very fundamental
issues in this case compensation and
team there was one person on his board
and it was a token person who is non
American we're going to see some massive
challenges coming out sometimes so big
that I think you'll see some companies
being forced to withdraw from being as
infinite as they'd like because they
can't cope with it organization a
massive massive issue so let me just say
globalization don't just think of it in
terms of markets and supply chains
that's obvious everyone's got that
assuring it's a second and like
everything in management it's the second
or third order consequences where things
get really interesting and this is going
to get very very interesting third point
deeply obvious but again I apologize for
raising it is absolutely crucial is
technology technology is an enduring
issue again like globalization
particularly and on the internet
everything that was promised in the
internet in 1997 turned out to be true
the only people got really burned with
the financial community everything else
in terms of impact on business in terms
of our organization's turned out to be
true it is absolutely fundamentally
transforming the way business is done
again I'm sure you've been told this
often but when you see what I do and see
it really is transformation mean
something when you see what it's doing
it is fundamental and the biggest impact
which again has not yet been seen is
what it does to human behaviour at the
moment its transformed processes and
it's transformed distribution
possibilities through channels but the
human dimension is only now just being
understood you'll see organizations with
very strong cultures unwinding because
of their dependence on technology
they're doing incredibly well some of
them because they're dependent on
technologies but that cultures are
unwinding because the human glue has
been replaced by technology this matters
if you want to be an enduring
organization so that's theme number
three a fresh look at technology which
goes way beyond the usual approaches
using it to optimize processes second
third order consequences again a lot of
it comes back to organization fourth one
capabilities this is particularly the
hot theme in Asia it is not an to talk
to this group about capabilities unfair
you do not represent the world please
remember that you do not represent the
world you represent a very very very
small and privileged part of the world
capabilities not just talent not just
intellect the deep knowledge whether
it's about marketing about finance is a
massive problem particularly in very
fast-growing economies like India and
China also in Russia central Eastern
Europe also I would suggest in the
States as well
there is a huge capability deficiency
people often talk about the biggest
stumbling block to growth in China is
resources and environmental pressures
it's not every CEO I talked to that says
we are sort of management particularly
general management particular commercial
management particularly financial and
marketing people it's people there's
going to be a tremendous tremendous
focus on capabilities it's a wonderful
time for you to be in
in the talent pool at the moment and I
think this is at the beginning not at
the end particularly when you look at
the Asian economies and by capabilities
I don't mean just very bright people
that's the talent side it's no good
being great at tennis if you should be
playing cricket so this is about getting
the right capabilities in the right
place and time and many companies have
very skewed capable skewed capabilities
I've mentioned China I think it's true
in many technology companies in the US
have great technical capabilities very
weak marketing skills and China they
have tremendous engineering talent the
output of PhDs in China is greater than
that of the US and Europe put together
every year just to give an example
they're not short of engineers but they
are shorter people so this is matching
the capabilities that you need with the
strategies of your organization and it
only means something when you get very
micro about what skills and what talents
and there's a massive problem building
out there
the final one which I'll finish on
before I conclude by talking about what
does it mean going forward a leadership
is an issue that I've written about and
I'll try not to Witter on about is
particularly for very large successful
companies what's the nature of their
relationship with the societies in which
they operate this is sometimes called
much to my fury corporate social
responsibility you know what I'm talking
about but the relationship of successful
companies to the societies in which they
operate and this is petunia this is
societies as citizens societies as
government societies as regulators what
is the role how do they interface with
them how do they influence them how they
influenced by them is a massive massive
issue and it's not just a Western NGO
thing this is a big issue and I think
it's going to come a huge issue in Japan
in China location in India as well it's
a massive business problem this it's a
massive business opportunity as well so
I would just say that's another theme
that I hear it is not just a creature of
the liberal left press in the West so if
I could pick up five themes that I think
certainly the last four and I think the
first one will endear it is this notion
of the interface between growth risk and
time frames and
the tools technical analytical as well
as judgmental that help you shape that
and how you communicate that your
employees and investors really thinking
through the second or third order
consequences of globalization beyond
supply chain economics and customers
getting much deeper into the
organizational space really thinking
through the second third fourth order
consequences of Technology particularly
internet not only the internet forcely
getting very precise about capabilities
it's not just talented people it's very
very precise about the caper as you need
and then finally particularly for large
firms wherever they be the relationship
of these large firms to the societies in
which they operate I think those as I've
interpreted right based on my
conversation of five shaping fees I
haven't talked about marketing
operations pricing organizational design
these are what I call the usual suspects
if you can't be competitive on costs if
you can't market properly if you can't
get your customers sorted out games over
it doesn't matter where you are you have
to get those right I just don't want to
talk about them I don't think they're
game to differentiate those are what I
call platform tickets you have to get
those right interesting twenty years ago
people said if you get those right you
have a competitive advantage we've moved
on from that that's that's the ticket to
pay now just in conclusion if this is
right one person's view my background
and Prejudice if what I said is right
what does it mean what types of
leadership are likely leadership skills
are likely to be needed going forward
irrespective of the country or the
geography or in my view the industry you
come from obviously there's going to be
differences personally I think we are
seeing and we're going to see a lot more
of a move from what I call hard types of
skills towards that what is tradition
called softer types of skills analysis
strategy engineering technology are
crucial but I think they have to be
interspersed with people who understand
how teams work how organizations work
how people are motivated if as I believe
to be the case the 1980s was the decade
of strategy the money was made
strategy remember Michael Porter
competitive advantages great stuff and
that was where the big bucks are made
1990s was technology that's where the
really big bucks are made people got
early on technology I believe the next
fifteen years is people who get the
productivity equation right through
people I think we're going to
differentiate themselves and I call that
hard to soft it's really hard and soft
you've got to be rigorous you've got the
difference but I think this human
dimension people productivity I call it
and particularly move to a knowledge
economy where the greatest asset the
people you have blah blah blah all the
stuff you hear thinking through what
that really means is absolutely going to
be crucial the types of skills you
recruit the types of people you croute I
also think it's the reason why if you
didn't make it possible why women I
think are going to be very successful in
the next 10 or 15 years because they I
hate to generalize can often naturally
relate to that people who naturally
think in those ways I think will become
more and more valuable resources
I think global culture and mindset is
going to be crucial it's an obvious
point to say but if you believe what I
said about globalization it's not just
enough to spend two or three years in
different countries the number of people
particularly Americans of any Americans
who've been two or three years you know
for 20 years but still don't have a
global mindset is staggering people who
really understand how different
countries work how different people work
I think is going to be crucial so that
nationality doesn't become a source of
even comment that's to me would be the
ultimate definition of a winning company
so having a true global culture go back
to my story about the CFO a culture that
you can naturally deal with that you can
accommodate that people can move from
Malaysia or Sri Lanka to a head office
in Chicago it takes one day before
they're productive that's what has to be
the mindset huge challenge challenge
number three I think it's particularly
true for CEOs but I think it's going to
be increasingly true for all managers
with a global company is what I call the
need for diplomacy I stole this word off
John Brown at BP he's it is a wonderful
idea and a wonderful concept by
diplomacy the ability to influence
events to persuade people while always
being respected
of yourself I think that's going to
become a crucial skill internally and
externally Trust is going to become a
massively important word power status
hierarchy bigbanana I think these are
gonna be I hope they are dead words in
10-15 years time I call that diplomacy
I'm sorry I stole the word I think it's
a wonderful word and then the final
point I'll leave on is they need to be
flexible flexible I think both as
personally personalities and
organizations I talked a little bit
about for McKinsey I think organizations
are going to have you very flexible in
the way they offer careers to their
employees particularly if as I believe
women are going to be more active but
increasingly for men and we are seeing
and I'm sure everybody else is this
demand for much different up set of
opportunities and the way you live life
and go work I think that's going to be
true for everyone
I think being very flexible being very
accommodating adjusting careers to the
individual rather than at the moment
whatever anybody says individuals to the
careers most of the I feel terrible but
that's the way we do things here number
times I heard there aints gonna have to
change what does it need for you to make
it work what does it need for you to
make this work we believe in you so I
think this idea of flexibility
individual and institution is going to
come absolutely crucial which runs
against the career trends the last 50
years so if I can just pick out the
implications of those trends about hard
to soft a true global culture and
mindset the importance of diplomacy as
the skill and I would add you to study
history around diplomacy to see what
that I think history is the best way to
learn that particular skill and the
importance of flexibility both personal
and institutional I think will be
defining skills over the next 10 years I
probably took longer than I should have
done already
I will stop there on that particular
note I hope I've given you at least my
sense of based on tools and discussions
with CEOs and colleagues and partners of
mind about what's on the mind of CEOs
across the world and at least one
person's interpretation of what that
might mean for new leadership skills
going forward